all right Salem
hello Salem where'd you grow up where
are you from originally uh San Diego I
grew up in San Diego
moved to the IE so like Riverside area
when I was in high school
and then from there around like 2021 I
went came to LA
what's your childhood like
um it was good honestly I think some
people when they find out like you're a
sex worker they assume it was bad but
mine was good we were poor but it was
happy family parents very much in love
still together it's nice to hear yeah
what kind of kid were you in high school
what kind of kid was I oh god
um Stoner kid
Stoner skater Punk kid yeah pretty much
into metal into music a lot didn't care
so much for school
um I don't know I get my parents like
not my parents my teachers really liked
me
so I got away with a lot like I wouldn't
do homework a lot of the time but they
would offer me deals like if you do this
project I'll pass you so past like very
bottom of my class but I did it you
graduated yeah I graduated and you got
into sex work when I got into sex work
so stripping I got into sex work once I
came out here so when I was like 20 21
but I had before I knew what sex work
was I had I guess started sugaring when
I was like in high school like
1617 which looking back on it it's
terrible but we were like very much
middle class like lower middle class so
my parents wouldn't give me like money
to do things
so but older men would huh but older men
would older men would so I like ended up
through friends
finding out about like
websites where you could like go on
there and people take you to dinner and
like take you shopping and like now in
hindsight I'm like oh like you were the
very like small community of like girls
that were willing to just do it for free
I guess
now being older I'm like that's insane
but yeah that's where I got into
sugaring and everything how old are you
now I'm gonna be 30. so you've been
doing this for almost a decade very long
time in different forms different forms
yeah but what kind of work have you done
um so before I was just sugaring and
then I got into stripping sugaring mean
sugar baby yeah sugar baby and then um
got into stripping and then
I got into stripping but I still had my
career I worked in fashion so I actually
was a photographer and so
um
from there I was doing stripping
part-time and then
had the CEO of the company I was working
for his dad was the warehouse manager
and he
ended up
trying to assault me essentially like I
was leaving work one day and I was going
through the warehouse and we were the
only two in the building and he started
to kiss me and then I ran out and he
tried following me and pulling me back
in so I ended up quitting fashion and
getting Severance paying going fully
into dancing and then um from there got
into like the poker games like the
private events
um
I don't know I started doing massages
during quarantine I don't know I've done
everything except for
digital walk the blade stuff like that I
guess through just the years I found
like the websites you can go on do more
so full service all that stuff
and what's your personal experience been
to have been a sex worker for the last
nine years
um foreign
so my personal experience
it's been rough obviously it comes with
the territory
um I don't know I think maybe personally
because of my background with my career
and like applying myself into sex work
as seen it as a business running my week
as like a five day a week eight hour
days like respond to messages and stuff
like that I've been able to stray away
from I guess more of like the dark side
of it but obviously it still comes with
the territory of like
assaults
um situations like shootings
fighting all those things so it's been a
journey it's been a roller coaster uh at
this point in time being older I myself
try and apply my personal experience to
helping
new baby sex workers so I do Mentor sex
workers I help them I guess instead of
them jumping into it and learning
everything I help them I just tell them
where to go what's the safest way to do
it teach them how to like verify these
dudes and show them like what background
checking apps to use how to run their
numbers like everything I guess just to
make sure that you could be the safest
situation that you can be teaching is
not to make the same mistakes yeah yeah
like you know I don't know I know that
there's some people that think that they
need to pay their dues and figure it out
but in my personal opinion
just because I had mentors and stuff
like that I think it's like paying it
forward like
girls don't have to deal with like the
huge trauma of it like I can tell them
how to avoid it so that maybe they won't
be so traumatized but there's so many
dangers hazards yeah there's a lot
there's a lot of scams that yeah
yeah I mean there is like the saying
within sex work it's like we protect
each other so I fully believe that and I
have mixed feelings about it always but
all together I do believe that this is a
path a lot of marginalized communities
find themselves in and
why not make it safe as possible for
them
do you think it should be legalized to I
do I fully support decrim I am an
activist within the community I do a lot
for towards trying to push for
decriminalization I've spoken to like
the D.A of Kentucky that did his stance
on not Prosecuting consensual sex work I
spoke to him and asked him for advice on
how to apply it within California and
all that stuff he gave me some thoughts
but I still need to figure out how to
like go forward and like approach a D.A
without feeling like I'm going to [ __ ]
myself over you know but yeah I fully
support dcream I think but even as a
stripper you're still approached oh 100
constantly to do much more than just
strip right yeah yeah I mean I've had
both sides of it I think after Foster
sesta I mean I was working when I saw
the law pass
Ed I went to work that night and we went
from like the average of like 10 girls
on a shift to like seeing every 30
minutes someone walking into audition
and within a few months we went from it
being average 10 girls on the slow night
so 30 to 40 because obviously if you
pull away all the internet platforms
that these girls were using
than where else are the Johns and the
girl is going to meet each other a strip
club so definitely have seen a
transition of before it was such like a
like almost like a girls knew that
there's extras happy in the club to like
oh no it's a given like girls do extras
in the club and like
every other customer is looking for it
obviously strip clubs can be pretty
seedy
yeah I mean
I mean I've traveled to a few States and
I don't think I found one that isn't and
they're dangerous as well yeah they're
very dangerous
um
shootings stabbings I've gone into
fights with pimps in the club
um yeah you mentioned a couple shootings
at two of the clubs you worked at yeah
so earlier this year in March I was
working at sin in North Hills and it was
actually
the manager's birthday so
there is some politics within the club
that a lot of girls weren't working for
a long time and um but because it was a
certain manager's birthday we all came
in so there was like on a Sunday night
probably like 30 or more of us and um 30
girls yeah and so a lot of us have been
there makes it hard to make money right
it does but I think I mean that club I
won't say this for every Club but that
club was a very much hole in the wall
like gem in the rough of like all of us
work together no one really stepped on
anyone's toes it wasn't a surprise if
like you met a customer and like
they weren't your type but you knew who
they were so you'd immediately go and
grab the girl like everyone wanted to
make money like it was a really good
club before it kind of went to [ __ ] so
it was his birthday and um
we were all in office like happy
birthday like singing and whatnot and
then um one of the girls she was like oh
my boyfriend's outside I gotta go and
we're like okay so we like all walked
out she got walked out as soon as the
door shut like not even 10 seconds later
there's like two gunshots and like me
and my friend are staying on the couch
and we were the first to like react
where we were like that was a gunshot
and immediately started rounding up the
girl's time to go to The Locker Room
Security ran outside
and I don't know exactly what happened I
didn't ask questions to my friend but
what is the story that's told is that
there is a customer that was in the club
that got into an argument with her
boyfriend and as she was walking out he
walked up and shot her boyfriend and he
died
so
um that was pretty [ __ ] like it's really
bad so after that
um
the LA Times put all of the girls at my
club on blast so I put the LA Times on
blast and I did a call for Action where
I was like Hey like it's not okay to use
trauma porn of like literally girls that
console each other like when this
happened
um
at least censor their faces because they
put their faces like fully like
literally crying each other's arms like
front page and so um put their phone
number up and I was like can you guys
call in ask them to remove the photos
and like behalf of my club and then a
few people like I guess a bunch of
people called so they changed the number
so I went and found all of the editors
of the LA Times in California and the
writers emails and they put that on
blast and a few hundred people email
them got a response later in the day
they're like we changed the photo I was
like all right cool so after that
I had because I was the veteran at that
club I had told them um
don't work at this club it's not safe
um about 30 or more girls left so it had
been
since March since I worked in the valley
and when I went to this new club I went
to that I really liked I was telling
them they're like oh I just stopped
working in the valley and I'm like oh
because the shooting at my club and
they're all like got a little awkward
and I'm like what they're like well we
just reopened but we got shut down
because there is a shooting here and I
was like oh but that one from what I'm
told was actually inside the club so I
don't know the details but I'm like of
course that's
as The Story Goes what does your family
think of you doing this kind of work
um
very much don't ask don't tell based
a few years ago my mom had I went to
visit and I my mom's very typical
Mexican mother so I left my bag in the
guest room and I came back and she had
washed all my outfits and they were all
hanging to dry
and I was like oh Lord and I went in and
she like calls me onto the living room
and she's just like
I get it like taking care of yourself
and make your money be safe she's like I
hope that you don't stay in this life
forever and I was like okay and that was
like years ago
and then
nothing really was heard about it no one
really said anything and then um I have
a really insane stalker and he um
did a background check on my family I
guess when he couldn't like get a hold
of me and got a hold of my dad's number
and started texting my dad like very
insane things but amongst those things
he was like your daughter is a stripper
at a gentleman's club blah blah blah
blah
and like God bless my father like he's
like my number one supporter so all he
was like are you okay and I'm like I'm
okay he's insane he's just like what's
the story and I'm like it's a customer
that got really obsessed with me I had
to cut him off I'm 86 for my clubs
like completely like
change numbers everything so he wouldn't
be able to get a hold of me and from
then he like took it further and like
started just like going and saying like
sending messages to people on my
Instagram like anyone that he would see
interact with me on social media would
send them crazy [ __ ] and escalate it's
like reaching out to my parents wow so
but since then I don't know I think that
because throughout the years
um have obviously shown like I have my
own home I have a dog I take care of him
I'm fine and take care of myself I pay
my bills
I have a nice car you know like
everything I've been able to give them
money it's lifestyle
yeah I mean you make good money I make
good money so I think once they saw that
they were just like okay she's fine
would you recommend this lifestyle to a
young lady who's thinking to do it
um if you would have asked me a few
years ago I would say yes
now just recently after like
covid and just seeing how kind of like
erratic everything has been I took the
mental stance that I wasn't going to
anymore because I was very vocally a
mentor so I would have girls reach out
to me on Instagram all the time like I
want to get into sex work can you help
me and just this year I was like
ethically and like me personally I don't
think I can like if you get into it
yourself and you decide to find me and
reach out to me and ask me to help you
okay but I will not be the one to be
like here's everything you need to do to
start like I can't do that anymore I
I wouldn't feel okay
saying that to someone and then finding
out they went and like got raped or like
got robbed you know like I wouldn't feel
okay because then they're gonna call me
and be like this happened I'm gonna be
like [ __ ] hey being a female in this
lifestyle brings about
all kinds of
aggressive men all kinds of crazy
dangerous
situations
I'm sure you've had more than your share
yeah
um
so after fast assessor and everything
was taken away online and um the clubs
became so oversaturated
um I started doing private events more
private events more private bookings and
a DJ that I had worked with reached out
to me and he's like
I am going to be DJing adult con it's
gonna be a pop-up strip club do you want
to come in and I'm like yeah of course
would love to so I show up I go
um it's a bunch of girls I actually
worked with a bunch of Valley girls
mainly and um worked the whole first day
make really good money and then the
second day I was running late so I
didn't even have a chance to take the
money I had had out of my bag I just
went straight to the convention center
and um
work that day
um we were drinking but
I had a tall can so it wasn't even like
I was drunk
and um I remember finishing the day and
everyone's starting to wrap up and then
fast forward I wake up in the house
and
I'm being watched by a bunch of people
and
I have to fight my way out there's like
three dudes I had to like
physically fight my way out got past
them ran out the door jumped the fence
ran down the street and then um
had
a woman random woman came up to me on
the sidewalk and she's like do you need
help and I'm like yes I need to get home
she's like okay I'm like where are we
she's like we're in Englewood I'm like
that's crazy I was just in downtown but
okay
so she ends up calling someone he takes
me I was staying with my friend at the
time
at the UCLA housing so she had a spare
room that she would rent out to dancers
so I was staying there I get there I
don't know what time it is or anything
I'm just like so focused on getting home
I have none of my stuff
um I get home
and my the roommates my roommates are
awake stressed out I get in
um well I knock on the door they open
the door they're like freaking out
they're like you've been missing for
hours I'm like what time is it they're
like 5 a.m I hadn't seen myself I think
the adrenaline of everything I I just
didn't really
take note
my one friend Amelia poncined me she'll
start sobbing and I'm just like okay my
other friend immediately starts getting
dressed she's like we need to take you
to the ER I go to the bathroom I'm
bleeding everywhere
um I go to the ER
at the UCLA campus and
they're
taking of me I have like knife wounds on
my arm on my back I have like scrapes
all over my face
and um
I let them know I'm like I'm a stripper
I was working La con got roofied I I
woke up in a house they're like okay we
need to transfer you to the rape
Treatment Center so they transfer me
over there Santa Monica and I let them
know that I had woke up in Inglewood so
they're like okay so they called
Englewood PD and had them meet me there
so I go there they
um
are helping me checking me and
everything covered in bruises
um and
yeah
um Inglewood comes they take my
statement and let them know as much as I
can they the rape Treatment Center I
guess the city of La when something like
that happens you're a victim of crime so
they assigned me a therapist so she sat
in during the whole interview and
everything I'm like okay the end of the
interview she's like
keeping it real
you probably won't hear anything back
um there probably won't be a follow-up
probably there probably won't be
anything and she's like
um here's all your paperwork to file for
the victim of crime
she's like they'll compensate you for
whatever you say you got robbed stolen
money possessions whatever all that
stuff
I'm like okay so the only good thing
that I guess came out of that was when I
was at the rape Treatment Center and
they checked me the nurses completely
shocked but they're like they didn't
rape you
she's like you have bruises everywhere
she's like but that's the only place
that's fine she's like I don't know if
maybe you fought so hard who knows but
that's the only thing that we can like
give you as like the peace of mind I was
like all right so try to follow up
didn't hear anything
um I mean it goes hand in hand with sex
work it's like the no human involved
[ __ ] they don't care like never saw
anything about it
um
contacted the DJ I worked with he was
like I'll try and talk to the club see
if there's anything we can do try to
call Convention Center never got
responses nothing so
nothing came of it I like I went to work
the next day because I had to make money
business as usual business as usual they
robbed me of like at least two thousand
dollars like that I had made between
like
being tipped on stage and we were able
to price our own dances and I was
charging 50 lap dances and made good
money so they robbed me of that and plus
all my valuables had bills to pay
so I was like okay my savings could only
do so much so went to work
and then after working for a week I took
a bus to the bay where my family like is
from my friends are they like head out
for a week and just kind of let myself
fall apart and then came back down and I
had a girl that had wanted me to Mentor
her so came back down and went back to
the club and started mentoring her like
you know drugs are part of the lifestyle
too right yeah yeah so
I'm epileptic so I always say it's
blessing in disguise regardless of even
if I wanted to I don't do drugs I can't
like I can't but I've definitely seen
obviously girls come into the club and
then within a few months
there in the lifestyle of partying and
on drugs and all that stuff and I don't
know I very much pushed being a sober
stripper but not everyone does but it's
it is a part of it it's sad to see but
I guess it happens how does this
lifestyle get to you emotionally
um
it's a love hate
it's definitely a love hate I have
um
I have a friend from Louisiana and she's
also a sex worker and she's a writer and
she wrote a piece a few months ago and
in it it says one of the lines is like
some days I hate this job but most days
it's the closest I found to God and I
think that that might have some truth to
it I don't know
um
definitely takes like the rose-colored
glasses off of reality there's
definitely a whole world that I realize
a lot of my friends will never
experience
um I have a soft spot for it
I have a hate towards the customers
The Pimps the tricks all of them
um I wish that part didn't apply but I
think the community of it could be
really beautiful the way that you can
see that girls really push for each
other the just like helping each other
with making ends meet
providing shelter when someone needs it
coming to the safe like when they need
like saving you know like all that stuff
I think it's one of the few communities
that I really see that girls ride for
each other as hard they do is your view
of men changed because 100 yes I think
before I already had like a pretty bad
perception
and then your dad your dad was a good
example it sounds like yeah my dad's
amazing I [ __ ] thank god
um I owe him a lot like he trained me to
box as I was a kid and like has trained
me to fight my whole life so I think
that that really helped me in this
lifestyle definitely had to fight my way
out of some shitty situations but your
customers yeah some customers some
situations
um
I have fought pimps I fought a pimp at
the club in Orange County with a couple
of my homegirls because
he was in the VIP room in his um
his girl was on the floor recording
dancers and sending them to him he would
like go and like take the VIP and like
try and recruit them
me and my two homegirls came in and it
was like beginning of night shifts I
guess he had been there all day and I'm
staying on the couch and my homegirl
goes on stage and she signals to me
she's like this girl's recording me so I
walk up to her and I'm like
um
delete the video and she just like
stares at me so in Spanish I'm like
she looks at me she's like why and I'm
like oh you speak English like well
because we don't want you to record in
here it's not okay
she like dismisses me so I'm like okay I
walk up to the manager I let him know
I'm like hey she's recording I said I
like blah blah
they go over they make or delete it but
it's an iPhone she needs to delete it
from the deleted
so I gotta go on stage and my homegirl
gets off and she's like did she delete
it and I'm like it's in her delete it
and she's like okay so she walks over to
her I go on stage I literally just get
in front of where they are and I'm just
like twerking and spot like watching
what's going on
and they get into it
um
they start fighting I jump off stage to
help
security jumps in at that point pimp
walks out of the VIP room he jumps in
we're all brawling
and it's a fiasco we had just started at
that club so security is like
manhandling us and I'm in my mind I'm
like okay I'm a stripper they don't have
respect for us like they're gonna beat
the [ __ ] out of us so like we're it's
just like a all-out [ __ ] brawl and
like we get ends up being dragged and
like they like kick the people out and
we get sat down in the office and we all
get fired and I'm like why did we get
fired like the waitress over here is
saying that they've been in here all day
recording you guys aren't doing your job
like why why is it on us and they're
just like no you guys we can't have that
in here and I'm like okay well we're the
only one that was willing to take a
[ __ ] stance of it like how is that my
fault but yeah I guess
that [ __ ] happens all the time it's not
the first time and wasn't the last time
I ended up finding like a pimp and
everything so do you think you're
addicted to the fast money
um
yes and no
and yes and now I've definitely gone
back and forth was in my career like I
have like a pretty good career in retail
and like fashion I've gone back and
forth with it but I can't accept the
lack of respect and like the civilian
Workforce
which is my big problem with it like I
was a store manager at PacSun like for a
little bit while like taking a break
from full-time dancing and like just
retailing itself is [ __ ] and like the
way that corporations run everything the
lack of respect for like the employees
which half of them are teenagers I just
couldn't do it like literally was in the
office one day and I was like on the
phone with like the district manager and
she's like talking to me kind of crazy
and I'm just like
and she's like what I'm like I quit
she's like really I'm like I quit I'm
like I I can't do this I literally
I can go to the club and like not deal
with this like
so I think that's the aspect
um
I don't know club's not really that much
fast money these days kind of rough so
yes and no if you had your life to live
all over again would you
have done something differently
the funny part is I tell people all the
time that I would start dancing at 18
versus saying 20 21. but I don't know
um I've lived a beautiful life
regardless of everything I've gone
through I think
um I don't know I do take pride in being
able to be in the club and take care of
other girls and stuff like that so I
don't know I really don't
back to your customers the men you
didn't didn't totally answer the
question which is how you see men
differently
differently um
trust them
um
I don't know I've seen every type of guy
in the club businessman CD men Trappers
scammers everything
they're all the same honestly
I can say that the people in my life are
different I guess I don't know I'm
talking about I guess the customer base
of like the club I think that they're
all pretty [ __ ] but I do like my brother
he's
never step foot in a club he's very like
like wholesome human
so I think that it depends on the guy
but the ones that I experience I just I
don't trust them at this point I'm
definitely jaded in that sense like
there's all kinds of people out there
yeah
it's just in the strip club you're only
finding one yeah it doesn't matter the
face they're all the same
is it a lonely lifestyle for you
ah yeah yeah yeah
um try to date can't do it I think maybe
in the beginning so when I started
dancing I was single so I went like
three years no relationship just working
then I got into a relationship and
having to deal with someone else's
perspective and feelings being
desensitized to it them not being
desensitized not understanding why
they're so upset it was really hard so
I've gone to a pretty volatile
relationship it was with a woman we were
together for three years it was pretty
rough because she just really couldn't
wrap her head around it and that was
like the base of all of our problems
since leaving that relationship it's
been like now like three three years I
think three four years that I've been
single and I'll try to date
be with a guy or like be with a girl for
like a month everything's fine I let
them know I'm a sex worker they're like
that's great
and then a month into it they're like I
don't like it and I'm just like okay
well what can I do how can I reassure
you tell me I try it doesn't work I'm
like okay I'm not the one for you
because at this point in time I think
my stability is a priority over love I
don't know maybe I'll never find it who
knows but at least I'll be comfortable
like and at least my dog will have food
and I won't have to be stressing
so that to me is a priority so I guess
yes in the sense of being lonely and
loved am I lonely in life no I have like
my family I have my friends I have my
dog so yeah but yeah what do you think
people outside of that lifestyle don't
understand about
girls that do this
um you're not a bunch of sex crazed
women you're just trying to survive
right yeah you figured out a way to make
good money yeah I think some people like
I mean sure I've met some girls that are
like worse sex crazies and found a way
to make money I think they get
desensitized too but um no we're not all
a bunch of sex crazed women it's just a
job like the one thing I always try to
deal with in relationships is that they
would like be so stuck on the fact that
like oh you're dancing on these men like
do you find them attractive I'm like
once I'm done with the dance I forget
what they look like unless they like
paid me a big amount of money to like
remember
even then I forgot like it's completely
like okay on to the next like
meet my sales goal like meet my like
weekly goal meet my monthly goal like
that's how I view it and I think that
it's hard for other people on the other
side to just see it as that because
their experiences with intimacy or with
other people have so much value to it or
so much weight that they can't
understand how you can just take that
out and make it a simple transaction
which like at the end of the day it is
do you eventually start because you've
been doing this for almost a decade do
you start making a connection between
money and love that can't be
separated yes and no
that you like the person
I end up with or I would be with has to
have money
um but
when it goes sour there's always that
part of me that's like I
like especially if I'm dating a man I'm
just like why am I playing up with this
for free when I can literally go and
get paid to deal with this [ __ ] and like
I don't know how to deal with this [ __ ]
like I just be present you know so it's
like definitely in the back of my mind
when [ __ ] goes south that's one of the
first things that pops up that I'm just
like irritable about I'm just like I
spent so much time
just like that I could have been making
money like it just feels like a waste to
me but so I would like to think no but I
know to a certain point yes
and Salem what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
in your life
in my life is this far
um
I don't know I guess
put myself first
in all situations
um put my safety first 100 and my health
yeah
it's great
all right Salem thank you so much for
sharing your story of course thank you
for having me wish you lots of luck out
there all right thank you thank you